I want to start today with firings and
resignations over refusal to get
vaccinated at a variety of different
employers but specifically within health
and Hospital Systems we talked about
this on the bonus show a little bit
earlier in the week and we're going to
dig into some more details Jeremy
actually sent me
um a a couple of links here that I think
are interesting to look at from Becker's
Hospital review about what's going on in
a number of different Health Systems
let's review
1400 unvaccinated workers leave
northwell health a total of 1400
employees of New Hyde Park new
york-based northwell health either
resigned or were terminated for refusing
to get vaccinated against covet 19.
confirmed by a spokesperson
the departures announced one week after
New York State's mandate took effect
requiring health care workers get at
least one shot by September 27 included
about two dozen leaders at the
management level
or higher and represent under 2 percent
of northwell's employees with the
departures northwell is now reporting a
100 percent vaccinated Workforce this is
as it mentions in the article a 23
hospital system
and the largest health care provider in
New York state 76
000 employees and one of a few that have
terminated workers for choosing not to
get vaccinated so 1400 is a very big
number
at the same time it's under two percent
at the same time that's still at close
to two percent is much higher than the
one half of one percent to one percent
number that we previously thought about
as a likely outcome for many of these
requirements okay continuing Kaiser
suspends 2200 unvaccinated employees
Kaiser Permanente has placed just over
2200 employees on leave unpaid as of
October 4 for failing to comply with the
system's covid-19 vaccine requirement
Kaiser announced the vaccine mandate in
early August gave employees and
Physicians until September 30 to become
fully vaccinated for covid-19 or apply
for medical or religious exemption 78 of
the system's employees and Physicians
were vaccinated as of August 2nd that's
now more than 92 percent
the suspended employees make up less
than one percent of the nearly two
hundred forty thousand person Workforce
the number of employees on leave is
declining as more and more workers
comply employees have until December 1.
so we previously talked about this issue
of fired or unpaid leave unpaid leave
makes it easier for the employees to get
back into compliance and more quickly
come back to work uh which sounds pretty
good it's obviously uh from the
standpoint of the employer
easier and cheaper to retain someone
than to go and hire someone new
it also probably from the perspective of
the employee if you just get fired and
now even if you go and get vaccinated
you've got to reapply or do you look
somewhere else if you're just on unpaid
leave it's as simple as you go and get
vaccinated you can go back to work it
seems better for both employee and
employer and it does seem to be working
there they're at about one percent uh
non-compliant so far fully uh confirmed
non-compliant and then at another Health
System 400 Henry Ford workers leave
their jobs over the mandate
um this is the detroit-based Henry Ford
Health System
employees who left their jobs represent
about one percent one percent of the 33
000 person Workforce about 1900 workers
got exemptions from the vaccination
mandate more than 30 000 are vaccinated
they say all things considered were
losing a very small segment of our
Workforce I quite frankly wish that was
Zero but it's not said Bob riney
president of Health Care operations and
coo but it's a very small percentage and
our new hire process is already
offsetting the folks who declined to be
vaccinated and resigned so
all in all pretty good pretty good when
you look at the percentage uh one of the
big success stories on these mandates
and requirements is United Airlines
United Airlines is now this is already
this is as of last week actually I I
looked for newer numbers and couldn't
find them so this is already a week old
but United was down to only 320
unvaccinated people left they were at
593 at one point now down to 320.
that's out of 67
000 employees that is about half of one
percent and continuing to go down uh the
combination is 96 percent just got the
vaccine two thousand sought exemptions
and they were as of a week ago down to
320. this works this works and as we've
said before uh most people
want to stay in their job I was going to
say most people like their job that I
don't know about that's a little more
complicated but most people see the
value in staying in their job and at the
end of the day
um it's just an additional vaccine of
the many that may already be required it
is not constitutionally problematic
problematic it is not legally
problematic it is not morally
problematic it's just the right thing to
do and I think that I mean listen by
sheer math over time the number of
resistors will go down either because
they uh quit
or get fired or get vaccinated or some
get an exemption so I think these
numbers are going to continue to improve
and uh by definition places are getting
100 into compliance with their own
policies you can say the except that the
exemptions keep it short of 100
vaccinated technically you're still in
compliance if you get a valid exemption
some states allow religious some don't
some states allow moral objections some
doubt California is very very strict as
far as the exemption exemptions go but
if you look around the country what we
seem to be seeing at large employers is
that anywhere from half of one percent
to on the top end two-ish percent just
shy of two percent are refusing to get
vaccinated 98 99 and 99.5 vaccination at
uh at the population level would really
solve this pandemic of course not
everybody's eligible yet but getting to
that point at Big corporations is a
really really big deal we have been
following over the last 48 hours a rush
to Virtue signal by Republicans about
the United States border with Mexico
even Governors Senators members of
Congress from landlocked
non-border states are jumping in on the
bandwagon why well because as Joni Ernst
said in a video which we'll look at in
moment every state is now a border state
there first of all we have to understand
at the top level what's going on here
very little has changed under the Biden
Administration since the Trump
Administration as far as immigration
goes what has changed well as the
pandemic has eased depending on how you
look at it Mobility has re-increased and
a lot of the pent up demand from 2020 of
folks who did not move physically is now
ramping up that is responsible for part
of the increase we are seeing in folks
trying to cross
um seasonality plays a role we all we
talked about that in the spring in the
spring seasonality plays a role compared
to winter months under Trump that are
the basis for comparison but very little
has actually changed the Haitian
situation has not been particularly
dealt with by Joe Biden but that that's
uh
we don't think it's been dealt with well
in a different way than Republicans
don't think it's been dealt with well
but Republicans want to make it seem as
though Joe Biden has opened the Border
and is saying come on in to whoever the
hell wants to come in and I'm going to
play some clips for you here of a
variety of different Republicans jumping
in on the action here is Senator Joni
Ernst she's from Iowa Iowa a landlocked
state nowhere near the U.S Mexico border
listen to what she had to say the
reality is that every state
is now a border state all of the issues
that are affecting Texas and those that
are saying this sweep of illegals coming
across the border all of those issues
are now facing every other state yeah so
the argument that they are making is
people might come in through a border
state but then they use extremely
dehumanizing language like animals
cockroaches they just spread into all
these different states this is the gist
this is the imagery
um she goes on to go full Trump in her
fear-mongering talking about rapists
that's just they love talking about
rapists when they talk about the border
with an extraordinary number of people
crossing the border illegally of course
we're going to have rapists we're going
to have those that are terrorists we're
going to have other bad people entering
so if that vocabulary sounds familiar to
you it should because it's the exact
same vocabulary vocabulary with which
Donald Trump opened his 2016 uh
Republican uh uh primary campaign for
president really in 2015 is when he
actually started it uh then we go this
one's just amazing Ted Cruz puts on a
performance there was a shooting
yesterday
um in Texas and
um Ted Cruz has one of these incredible
performances where he does his sort of
like fake genuine very somber and then
pivots directly from the school shooting
to just go after Joe Biden for the
Border it's it's jaw it's weirdly
jarring and there have been far too many
of these at far too many schools and so
we are grateful for the courage and the
heroism the First Responders
and we are hopeful that that all of the
students or individuals who may have
been injured will will come through and
survive right
we're here today because of the Biden
border crisis
that continues to rage on the southern
border yeah
all right in there to hear a little bit
what a transition folks what a
transition and a very similar Dynamic
actually down at the border Republican
Texas governor Greg Abbott went down to
the Border they set up an entire dog and
pony show with you can see in the
background if you're watching I see a
chopper or two tanks I think armored
vehicles of different kinds and uh in
this clip you're going to hear Greg
Abbott talk about the influx of migrants
at the southern border take a listen
this is one of if not the most urgent
matter that we're facing in
it and it's time for the bite
Administration to wake up and get on the
job and do its job to protect the
sovereignty and safety of the United
States of America now remember very
little has changed this urgency is a
very concocted fabricated essentially
out of thin air what changed a Democrat
is in the white house that's what
changed the that we we have had an ebb
and flow on this issue we have no
permanent status for DACA recipients we
have not
um uh done all sorts of other types of
Reform that have been discussed for a
very long time
and this is a virtue signaling uh uh
party that they are essentially throwing
for themselves
um Greg Abbott was actually just to kind
of close the loop on the school shooting
as well Greg Abbott was asked about the
school shooter and he said listen this
is not about gun control because the
school shooter possessed the gun
illegally anyway
[Music]
so very importantly uh with regard to
the school shooting that took place
today as well as with uh really any
school shooting that I'm aware of the
gun that was possessed by the shooter
was possessed illegally and we will make
sure that laws are enforced and those
who act illegally will be held
accountable so listen first of all I'm
almost positive that we not long ago we
have so many school shootings in this
country it's hard to keep track but I'm
pretty sure that under the Trump
Administration
I'm not blaming Trump I'm just saying
during the time Trump was President
um there was a school shooting where the
guns were legally owned although maybe
that was the one
in California at the BART station
there's so many shootings in the United
States that it's difficult to keep track
uh but the point is they always go they
they go listen the laws don't matter
because the shooters will just get the
guns illegally but as we've said many
times before uh if you have more uniform
laws you make it more difficult to just
go to the neighboring place to get the
guns illegally because there are simply
fewer guns around at some point the
illegal gun was a legal gun and then
something happened
you know they like to say well if guns
are stolen that's no one's fault but of
course we know there are many other ways
that these guns ultimately end up in the
hands of people who do wrong with them
so on the shooting the normal stuff we
would expect but this border craze they
all of a sudden have Fox News with the
chirons and the lower thirds about panic
panic panic at The Border remember that
very modest changes uh in terms of
circumstances from Trump to Biden but
what's changed is Biden's a Democrat
Trump was a Republican and now
Republicans want to talk about this let
me know your thoughts you can find me on
Twitter at dpacman and remember that on
Tuesday October 19 we are doing a live
viewer Town Hall at 6 PM Eastern it will
be streamed live only on the second
YouTube channel Pac-Man Live find it at
youtube.com pacmanlife and uh 6 p.m
Eastern Tuesday October 19. consider
yourself invited to grab a membership on
my website joinpakman.com one of our
primary sources of revenue we do an
extra show every single day for our
members and you can use the coupon code
better21 to get a discount uh I was
browsing the David packman show
subreddit this morning you can find the
subreddit at davidpackman.com Reddit we
are close to looks like close to 33 000
subscribers to the subreddit it's free
I'm selling you nothing other than a
good time let's look at a few
interesting posts I spotted this morning
one is are you going to get the flu shot
this year
user lime guy actually put up a poll and
the poll results an unscientific survey
of our subreddit audience 40 I'm sorry
let's see here per oh percent I don't
even see percentages here it looks like
it's about
um two-thirds say yes they are going to
get the flu shot
um about one-seventh or once about
one-seventh say no and about a little
over that say maybe I got the flu shot
this year it felt great it really did I
had I think my arm bothered me a little
bit the next day uh otherwise no
symptoms much much uh much more fun than
the covet vaccination series let me put
it that way I felt pretty pretty lousy
after that
um listen in particular with hospitals
very full with covid
anything I can do to reduce the odds
that I need to go to the hospital for
another reason
or that a member of my family needs to
go to the hospital for whatever reason
I'm going to do and so yes I got the flu
shot I feel very good about it new data
says you can get the flu shot and the
covet shot very close together I think
Kathy Griffin even posted a video or a
picture of herself getting them at the
same time
um extremely safe and worth doing so I
hope people will do it
another user says has David ever spoken
about subreddits like Herman Cain award
I'd be curious to know what he thinks
about a subreddit like this I'd imagine
he's not a fan as he doesn't seem to
indulge in the schadenfreude many seem
to in regards to the pandemic to the
subreddit at large what are your
thoughts on the Herman Cain award is it
doing some modicum of Good by spreading
awareness or is the toxicity becoming a
problem users have gotten in touch with
extended family of the deceased
harassing them and some of the rhetoric
on the subreddit has escalated for my
part I'm a fan of getting people
vaccinated but none of the
aforementioned issues yeah I mean listen
the the doxing and the harassing family
members of those who died unvaccinated
from covid yeah that's a hard no for me
I do have no problem with and I've done
it on the show
highlighting
loud anti-vaccine voices
who told everybody not to get vaccinated
and said they weren't getting vaccinated
and then they got covered and then they
died not because I enjoy the fact that
they died but because I hope that they
are cautionary tales for other people to
go and get themselves vaccinated so to
the extent that on Herman Cain award
there is cheering and it's called Herman
Cain award for people who may not know
because Herman Cain died of covet as far
as we know and he may have gotten it at
a trump rally although it's speculative
it's not clear that that's actually the
case but that's the that's the the
reason for the name of the subreddit
um celebrating the deaths I'm not a fan
of and I've only looked at that
subreddit once and there was some
toxicity on it I won't lie but if we can
make uh if the death can become a
cautionary tale and get people
vaccinated either way someone tragically
died
but it doesn't have to be completely in
vain if it maybe helps somebody else
another post I spotted on the subreddit
how can these folks folks like the
teacher David showed video of very
recently who make the claim that they
don't want to put the vaccine into their
body and how it's their right Etc how
can they also simply ignore the option
for being tested with some frequency
instead the fact they ignore that makes
it look like they actually want to
infect people what possible issue would
they have with covet testing as a
replacement for getting the vaccine what
you have to remember is that they don't
want to do anything that is under the
umbrella of a mandate so
if the problem you're completely right
if the problem is vaccination and you
can skip vaccination with testing then
you say great I'll do the testing weekly
or I'll do the testing daily or whatever
is required by my employer agency or
whatever the case may be it's not really
just about the vaccine for some it's
about the vaccine but it's also about
not doing anything someone else tells
you to do
and so if you're being told you've got
to do one of these two things vaccine or
test it becomes less about the vaccine
and more about Freedom Liberty I'm going
to do whatever the hell I want to do now
we've already talked about how your
freedom to do something has to be
balanced against others Freedom not to
be uh damaged by your actions
conversation we've already had but it
exposes the fact that so many people who
say I just have a problem with the
vaccine also refuse to be tested or
don't want to be tested shows us it's
not really about the vaccine or at least
it's not only about the vaccine join the
subreddit at davidpackman.com Reddit
alright I'm gonna play for you just a
little bit a little bit of another one
of these bogus interviews with employees
from Facebook we've now had one or two
of these every single day the back story
of course is that we had these
whistleblower documents leaked uh we now
um actually learn the identity Francis
Haugen of The Whistleblower on 60
Minutes Sunday testified on Monday or
Tuesday of this week and Facebook has
been falling all over itself to respond
to the different claims including sort
of most importantly we could say
that they know Facebook and or Instagram
aren't so good for a lot of people's
mental health and that a lot of the
things that do most well on the
platforms are disinformation and things
that are bad for body image and so on
and so forth and they still allow the
algorithm at minimum if not encourage
the algorithm to surface those things
because it generates clicks and it
generates engagement keeps people on the
on the platform and generates ad Revenue
as a result so we had an interview on
NPR earlier in the week with one guy who
seemed completely unprepared we had an
interview from CNN on yesterday's show
with a woman who was sort of like
denying every claim that was being made
even though they were really non-denial
denials they were very squishy denials
now I have video here of Facebook's
Global head of security
Antigone Davis that name brings me back
to uh junior English Antigone Davis who
without Without Really denying that
pushing content that upsets people is
what they do says it's it wouldn't be
logical for Facebook to do it listen
very carefully to what she says it's
actually extraordinarily short-sighted
so if you think about somebody's
experience on the platform if they're
having a very negative experience at
some point they're going to turn away
from that from that negative experience
so to suggest that we'd optimize towards
something negative for the long-term
value of business just doesn't actually
it is illogical it doesn't make sense so
she's claiming it wouldn't make sense to
optimize for a type of content that
upsets people wouldn't make sense
because then people get upset and then
they leave the platform except it
doesn't happen it doesn't happen
partially because people are sort of
addicted to these platforms and you can
endlessly scroll and see what's the next
thing do I have notifications that
someone sent me a message partially
because there's a sort of like uh a slot
machine effect where you you might
scroll and see something cool or not and
so the variable reward system works to
keep people scrolling and a lot of
people might feel like crap but not
realize it's because of browsing social
media comparing yourself to others and
whatever else the case may be so she
first of all doesn't really deny she
just says it would be illogical it
ignores the fact that this is a business
model I mean like think about tobacco
the long-term tobacco cigarettes are not
optimized for the long term why because
they kill the users okay but in the
short term particularly because nicotine
is addictive you generate a ton of money
so the idea that it's not a it's not a
logical business model to do something
that in the long term hurts your
customers idiotic absolutely idiotic and
the denial is a very very soft and and
soft and Squishy denial as I like to
call it now
um in the midst of all this remember
Facebook also had an outage on Monday
Facebook has now told the story
of why they say the outage took place
the outage was the longest stretch of
downtime for Facebook since 2008.
to all the people in businesses around
the world who depend on us were sorry
said Facebook Facebook shares were down
five percent Monday up one percent
Tuesday
Facebook uh is saying that the issue was
caused by configuration changes on the
backbone routers
and what the changes were was not said
the changes caused quote issues that
interrupted the flow of traffic between
routers and Facebook's data centers
around the world
this disruption to network traffic had a
cascading effect on the way our data
centers communicate bringing our
services to a halt so for all of those
speculating that this was a deliberate
outage in order to try to smother the
revelations about the Facebook
whistleblower I understand why you think
that the more I've thought about it the
less likely I think it is the amount of
um reputational damage
that Facebook suffered
um as well as significant number of
hours during their at during which their
ads weren't running there was a
financial problem as well you could say
it was all worth it to smother The
Whistleblower stuff but everybody's
posting The Whistleblower stuff now
anyway so I am leaning against it having
been a deliberate outage but if you
disagree with me let me know and we'll
have more clips from these very strange
interviews with seemingly unprepared
Facebook Executives uh on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
so we've been talking for a while now I
mean really since the January 6th riots
uh about the different stories that
those who want to excuse what happened
on that day have been telling about what
took place many of these stories you've
heard before it wasn't really trumpist
in other words it was antifa in Disguise
or people pretending to be trumpists or
in direct conflict with that it was
trumpous but they weren't violent it was
peaceful
obviously those two can't both be true
but these are examples of conflicting
explanations for what took place or a
few people did the wrong thing and it
was less about politics but more about
those people being unhinged or whatever
and they should be punished but not too
too bad because for political reasons
they're being held without bail and it's
all too strict and the conditions aren't
good and one guy didn't get vegan food
and so on and so forth so there's been
all these different stories told the FBI
set it up Tucker Carlson played with
that one for a little while
Gonna Play a clip for you here which is
kind of like the next iteration the next
step in the evolution of this and this
is a clip of Newsmax host Greg Kelly uh
suggesting that Democrats set up the
riots and maybe even carried them out
maybe in some general sense Democrats
set the conditions for the riots but
maybe they actually just planned it they
they did it they did the whole thing so
let's just go to this clip I'm going to
play a couple minutes of it because even
the lead up is crazy again this is on
Newsmax this is really wacky weaponized
stuff let's get into it I loved it I
love the trolley I love King Friday he's
going to to show up eventually I loved
it as a child
as a four to seven year old child and
occasionally in college look the Land of
Make Believe is for children it is not
for adults but we are in Joe Biden's
America they want us to live in the land
of make believe they're going to pretend
imagine smearing Mr Rogers in order to
make this very ridiculous political
Point pretend
that black children aren't being killed
by other black children okay now this is
the black on black violence myth what do
I mean it's a myth are black people
killed by black people yeah
when you look at the actual data the
odds of a black person being killed by a
black person are within a couple
percentage points
of the odds of a white person being
killed by a white person we still have a
relatively segregated country and people
overall or around people like them and
thus are likely to be victimized by
people that are like them for years
we've known this they don't care this is
happening this is happening and it can't
be denied this is a crisis yet
no one wants to talk about it no one
wants to talk about this it is happening
and nothing is being done it has become
so bad under Joe Biden because well he's
in so much denial how about this the
crime wave the conventional crime I'm
talking about robberies everywhere
shootings and robberies you know black
lives matter the summer last year it led
to all kinds of help yourself to
anything you want in the store consider
how unhinged this is by the way these
are all unrelated issues that he wants
to put together as Biden caused all of
it it's racist to make an arrest or even
call the cops
this is bad bad stuff so in the Land of
Make-Believe Joe Biden's land none of
this stuff is happening but what is
happening the scourge of white supremacy
yes white supremacy is responsible for
all this stuff we had to go back quite
some way to find uh footage of this
white supremacy does exist now for
people who are look you know he's making
fun of we have to go back to 1925 to
show a rally of white supremacists of
course this whatever degree of of
problem you believe white supremacy is
today with the Advent of the internet
social media and other types of
communication
you don't need parades not everything
that lacks a parade doesn't exist I
think is the point that we should be
taking from this are some idiots who
believe in that and they're off in the
woods somewhere knock yourselves out
don't break the law and if you do well
you should be arrested here we go now um
January 6 is another fixture in the Land
of Make-Believe that this was the worst
thing that ever happened not that it was
a trespassing event not that Democrats
may have had a hand in setting the
conditions and even perhaps setting the
whole thing up whoa there's something to
talk about there all right all this
stuff is going on all the other stuff is
not going on but they're saying it's
going on okay so he just kind of goes
into completely wacky delusional stuff
at this point in time so this is this is
the next iteration where they've tried
to blame everyone other than themselves
however
when they blame democrats for the
insurrection
they're admitting there was an
Insurrection right like should we
consider that a victory to some degree
but this is another layer as to why as
I've been saying earlier this week these
folks have to be held accountable and
when I when I say that I mean the
Insiders need to be voted out of office
in 2022. they're not going to be many of
the Insiders are in dark red districts
and there's no chance that they're voted
out it's just not going to happen but we
need there to be consequences number one
in order to be able to say here are the
people it's not Democrats it's this list
of people who rioted and they've been
found guilty and sentenced and it's this
list of people in the House and Senate
and they've lost their seats we're not
going to get that not to the degree that
I would hope but it's what we would need
in order to undeniably be able to push
back against these horrible narratives
that are being created like maybe
Democrats not only set up the conditions
but actually set up the entire thing
there's a contingent that won't care
does a contingent that will always
believe it was antifa or it was peaceful
trumpists or what they're never going to
believe it but we want to be chipping
away and having something really
specific to say no it wasn't Democrats
not a single Democratic member of
Congress or whatever these were
trumpists they were prosecuted they were
found guilty they were they were
sentenced these are the elected
officials who did it and I I wish I
could say I was confident that we were
going to get that
I don't think that we are I I still
don't think that we are to the degree
that we really need it if you think
we're going to get those consequences
let me know when and how you think we're
going to get them because I don't think
that mostly the slaps on the wrist that
we're seeing right now
um are cutting it and we'll see there
are still many cases pending hey this is
um
this is really a disgusting story not
only of media propaganda but also in a
sense of Media consolidation
Reuters has done a very very good
special report about how the radical
outrageous right-wing media Network oan
one America News the people we would see
in the Press briefing room yelling
questions from the back at Trump and
even to jensaki to some degree
uh they are 90 funded by a t the same at
T who bought Warner media which owns CNN
so this story is about a lot of
different things the report on Reuters
is extensive and we're linking to it
okay we today for time purposes are
going to look at sort of a summary from
mediaite of the Reuters investigation
okay
uh one America news the self-styled news
channel that pumps out pro-trump
propaganda
has received tens of millions of dollars
in funding from at T according to a
stunning new report
Reuters Unearthed how the far right
channel which distinguished itself in
cable news by peddling the most extreme
2020 election conspiracy theories is
being propped up by the world's largest
Communications company
a Reuters review of Court records shows
the role a t played in creating and
funding oan a network that continues to
spread conspiracy theories about 2020
and covet the role that at T played in
the launch of oan was revealed by the
Network's founder Robert Herring senior
in a deposition obtained by Reuters
quote oin founder and chief executive
Robert Herring senior has testified that
the inspiration to launch oan in 2013
came from came from at T Executives they
told us they wanted a conservative
Network
they only had one which was Fox News and
they had seven others on the other
left-wing side when they said that I
jumped to it and built one since then at
T has been a crucial source of funds
flowing into oan providing tens of
millions in Revenue court records show
90 of oan's Revenue came from a contract
with at T owned TV platforms including
DirecTV
what makes this bizarre tail even
thornier a t owns Warner media which is
the parent company of CNN
CNN's parent company is funding oan and
again I encourage you to check out the
entire Reuters report so there are I
mean there are so many stories here guys
first of all
maybe antitrust laws are there for a
reason maybe we should be having more
than just a handful of internet service
providers who were vertically integrated
and also own the programming okay that's
that's number one we have many of these
laws on the books there's been no
appetite from Republicans Or democrats
really in enforcing this stuff you do
hear sometimes from Democrats we got to
break up this that the other thing we've
heard it from Bernie Elizabeth Warren
not uh uh nearly the topic that it
should be that's one story
Second Story
CNN
has done a bunch of critiques of oan
okay they've exposed oan's lack of
journalistic integrity and they did it
accurately
um does CNN know when they do that that
the parent company is the same they're
owned by Warner which is owned by a T
and A T is that it's not owned but is
the main funder of oan
it wasn't mentioned in the segments that
were done on CNN makes me wonder whether
they even know it if either way you
would think it's something that should
be disclosed now
full disclosure it appears as though at
T also owns this show no I'm kidding it
uh that's not the type of disclosure I'm
talking about it appears as though at T
is in the process of selling Warner
media so at some point the CNN oan
connection May no longer be true uh but
this is another example also of how we
have to remember the primary bias of
corporate media
is money
MSNBC
is Corporate media and editorially they
lean left
Fox News is Corporate media editorially
they don't just lean right I mean Fox is
on the right something different than
what MSNBC is on the left CNN
has been anti-trump I would say
objectively so because of the disasters
Trump did during his presidency but
fundamentally CNN is a for-profit entity
and that's the number one bias Above All
Else and
um we have to remember that a lot of
this stuff the technology for delivering
this stuff becomes invisible and we just
look at oh it's you know uh Rachel
Maddow here and then it's Hannity here
we've got to remember the technology has
its own biases and structure that kind
of overrides all of this other stuff and
at T we've got stuff that's considered
more left and stuff that's considered
basically we just want to be able to
monetize all these different things
that's the bottom line and um whether
ultimately we will see any serious
enforcement of antitrust I don't know
uh but there is certainly you know the
the problem is that even now that
Republicans talk about antitrust and
breaking up companies they're really
just wanting to break up social media or
control social media so that Twitter
Can't Ban conservatives like it's
completely cynical their Newfound desire
to deal with antitrust the laws have
been on the books for decades could have
been enforced all along and they just
don't want to do it so we'll see what
happens read the report from Reuters on
at T funding um oan we'll post a link to
it in the description to the YouTube
video and we'll be back right after this
all right I want to talk about some
Republican reactions to the recent
Facebook whistleblowers Revelations
allegations statements during the
testimony that happened earlier this
week that is going to give us a little
bit of an entryway into Matt Gates then
we'll talk about Matt Gates's recent
statements when actually questioned
about whether he's worried about the
possible building sex trafficking case
against him it's all really really wacky
but let's start first with the
um Facebook stuff okay so Francis Haugen
is The Whistleblower we learned the
identity of the Whistleblower Sunday
night on 60 Minutes Monday she testified
um in Washington DC
um Matt Gates is suggesting that The
Whistleblower may be a false flag
being advised by former Obama staffers
what it means to be a false flag
whistleblower I don't know the documents
have not been called uh inauthentic
Facebook has just rejected some people's
characterization of the documents
Facebook has denied that they do the
things the documents show that they do
but the documents have not been called
inauthentic and so it just always starts
to get conspiratorial and weird here's
Matt Gates appearing on of course oan
which we found out earlier today is uh
90 funded by a t let's start there sure
and that brings us to The
non-whistleblower Whistleblower I think
folks should really question whether or
not this is a false flag Miss Haugen is
apparently now being advised by members
of the Obama team that certainly doesn't
strike us as someone trying to advance
the conversation to democratize access
to information and when you get down to
the core of what she wants it is a basis
for Facebook to be able to discriminate
against viewpoints that they don't
particularly like so this is a couple
points here all right and then we're
going to look at a clip also of the
brilliant Madison cawthorne explaining
what he believes this is all about so a
couple different points here
um first of all
the idea that all of this is to be able
to further suppress right-wing
viewpoints on Facebook right wing
viewpoints dominate Facebook I mean just
just dominate Facebook you look at the
top posts on Facebook most days it's Ben
Shapiro
um it's Hannity
it's Dan bongino
occasionally there will be a Rachel
maddowclip it's Tucker
um it it's it's actually quite the
opposite in practice of what's going on
on Facebook uh reports that Mark
Zuckerberg has been meeting with Tucker
Carlson and other right-wing media
figures that doesn't mean that he
believes in their political views
necessarily but the idea that Facebook
is just very disrespectful to right-wing
viewpoints overwhelmingly right wing
nuttery is spreading on Facebook it's a
Nexus of this stuff
so that's Matt Gates then we go to
Madison cawthorne who in his sort of
mealy-mouthed way says kind of the same
thing this is all a way to try to
justify censorship of right Wingers no
but I don't think that he should be
forced out but you know I have to tell
you and this is purely conjecture yeah
I'm glad you mentioned that Madison good
good whistleblower they had come up to
Capitol Hill who went out onto 60
Minutes uh just on Sunday and then in 48
hours she wound up in front of Congress
let me tell you that's the fastest I've
ever seen Congress move now let's deal
with that first of all 60 Minutes films
their stuff well in advance it's an
edited produced show and there is no
question that people knew this was
happening this was airing on Sunday
night with all of the different legal
clearances that have to take place and
so many different things I don't know
when it was filmed the interview with
the Whistleblower Francis Hogan but the
idea that you know uh uh whoever right I
mean Chuck Schumer's sitting at home and
Sunday night the interview shows up on
TV and he calls and he says ma'am come
to Washington of course that's not the
way it happened so so just the timing
thing as part of the basis for this um
conspiracy really is what it is
conspiracy theory just doesn't pass the
sniff test I believe that she is
actually there to try and advocate for
more censorship and less freedom of
speech because this is an
anti-competition Marketplace for the
Facebook as long as there's more
regulations she didn't argue for that
she simply didn't argue for that
um and and so this is sort of the the
story that they are latching on to and
it's really really interesting because
there's this incredible
it's not even a hypocrisy but you have
this idea
of
they don't want regulation
but they want Facebook and some of these
social media platforms to be forced to
allow the right wing stuff to be
published which is regulation but then
when Congress actually acts and people
start asking questions and holding
hearings to say well maybe there should
be regulation they say no no that
regular that sent that type of
Regulation censorship wait so did you
want the because it's still regulation
to go to Facebook and say you've got to
publish everything Ben Shapiro says and
everything Madison carthorne says or
whatever the case may be that's very
heavy-handed government intrusion into a
private company's business model
publicly traded but it's not a
government entity is the point so that's
very heavy-handed regulation which they
want but then at the same time
Francis Haugen is brought to DC and
let's figure out what we can do and now
the fear is oh no no no Democrats are
going to try to regulate Facebook and to
try to live it's not about principles is
the point endlessly I've told you these
people
they claim to be about principles
they're not they're about whatever
justifies the outcome they want at the
time they'll tell you a is the reason
that the outcome should be the outcome
and the next day they'll tell you the
opposite of a as long as it points to
the outcome they want that's all they
care about so that's Matt Gates and
Madison cawthorne on Facebook let's
stick with Matt Gates now in our next
story and give you an update there so
um things are things are still happening
as far as Matt Gates and the possible
sex trafficking allegations uh article
from the Associated Press
about Joel Greenberg Joel Greenberg is
the friend of Matt Gates who pleaded
guilty earlier this year to sex
trafficking
he is asking a judge to postpone
sentencing until next year so he can
keep coordinating with Federal
authorities now our layperson's
understanding of this from the outside
is that Joel Greenberg's cooperation
goes specifically to the substance of
what Matt Gates did and what Matt Gates
was involved with that's the belief the
the idea of some kind of co-conspiracy
involving these individuals I'm using
that term colloquially not in the legal
sense so Joel Greenberg says give me
more time I'm going to keep giving
investigators stuff
which we believe might eventually be
used to charge Matt Gates Greenberg
asked uh to move the sentencing to next
march this will give the former local
tax collector from Orlando more time to
be interviewed by federal investigators
according to the court filing
which said the extension was unopposed
by prosecutors meaning they're probably
getting pretty good stuff
quote indeed Mr Greenberg's ongoing
cooperation which will not be completed
prior to his current sentencing date
could have an impact on his final
sentence he wants a lower sentence by
continuing to give them dirt Greenberg
is facing up to 12 years in prison
prison after pleading guilty at last May
to six federal crimes including sex
trafficking of a child identity theft
stocking wire fraud and conspiracy to
bribe a public official
um Gates was not mentioned in the plea
agreement but Greenberg's cooperation
could play a role in an ongoing
investigation into whether Gates paid a
17 year old girl for sex so let's now go
to some clips of Matt Gates Matt Gates
appeared on ABC3 I believe this is down
in Florida and he
um is asked about whether he's concerned
about uh what's going on with Joel
Greenberg and he says that he's not he's
more concerned about socialism are you
worried that you're going to be charged
based on Joel Greenberg's actions and
your associations with him and your
actions with him I'm not I'm way more
concerned about the socialism engulfing
our nation than the Scandal sex
trafficking no we're becoming socialist
what seems to be engulfing the media I'm
glad that people are able to view these
Anonymous baseless allegations against
me through the lens of of the extortion
effort that Steve Alford was a part of
that other people were a part of are you
worried and that by the way if you're if
you're hearing that and saying what on
Earth is that about uh Gates and I I
believe maybe even his dad is somehow
tied into this
they're claiming they're being extorted
or that Gates's dad was being extorted
or something like that uh then asked
more about Joel Greenberg and Gates
basically seems to throw him under the
bus and says he regrets ever having been
associated with Joel Greenberg here I
believe there may have been a time where
Greenberg swung by the office but it
certainly didn't have anything to do
with any bad acts on my partner no you
guys still friends or I'm assuming the
answers now no when when uh when I
became aware of some of Greenberg's
misdeeds I deeply regretted my
friendship with him and and misdeeds in
which Gates is believed to be involved
not know vote I want to speak to my
constituents go ahead because I do
believe that it's fair for the people of
Northwest Florida to judge me based on
the associations that I've had and I
deeply regret my association with Joel
Greenberg politically socially and
otherwise but when folks evaluate that I
hope they evaluate it alongside the good
work that I've done yeah unfortunately
the other stuff he's done is also
terrible now in Florida they may not
think that he's from a conservative part
of Florida represents a conservative
part of Florida they may not see it that
way but we still reasonably think
um Matt Gates could end up charged with
some pretty serious crimes and I told
you was it last week or was it Monday
must have been last week maybe it was
three years ago I don't know time time's
weird these days no I think it was last
week that Gates has hired a who's who
roster of lawyers who specialize in
defending against sex crimes now he's
entitled to do that everybody's entitled
to a defense he's innocent until proven
guilty hasn't even been charged yet you
tend to get lawyers expert in the
subject relevant to your interactions
with the law and so the fact that he's
hiring experts in defending sex crimes
certainly points to the probability or
possibility I guess better said that
such crimes uh may be what he is
ultimately charged with we're going to
follow it hopefully sooner than later
we'll know where this is going we have a
voicemail number which is 2192 David P
totally different vibe today for
voicemail it's a very personal voicemail
segment take a listen to this
hey David
um this is doggone from Atlanta Georgia
I'm 19. and I just had a good question
about what you eat for breakfast
honestly I think you should start a
health
segment maybe or even on your Clips or
something because
everyone everyone can benefit from David
tips well listen I am not going to give
any health advice here that I am not
qualified to do that and you should go
to I don't know who let doctor
nutritionist I don't know I will tell
you my typical breakfast repertoire we
need a break from the serious stuff
folks please don't come after me after
uh don't don't go I actually get a lot
of questions about my breakfast
um I am not a big Savory for breakfast
guy I'm sorry I'm not a big sweet for
breakfast guy I'm more of a Savory for
breakfast guy so sometimes I'll have a
croissant and a coffee all right now I
know the croissant is somewhat sweet but
that's like as sweet as I would go no
marmalades jams preserves uh or coolies
on it whatsoever just a plain croissant
gotta be a good grit you want crunchy on
the outside you know fluffy on the
inside and a coffee but more typically
like at home I don't tend to have
croissants
typical breakfast for me
I will
uh saute up
a slice or two of turkey bacon turkey
bacon turkey folks not regular bacon
um and an egg over medium and then uh
half an avocado that's like a perfect
breakfast for me from the standpoint of
savory and from the standpoint of uh
Protein Plus healthy fats plus fiber
it's it's really got everything there
um sometimes now this this people know
about my uh love affair we fell in love
with sweet potatoes and if I've got
roasted sweet potatoes from a previous
meal as leftovers I will sometimes take
a sweet potato
and make some vertical Cuts almost to
get me like an English muffin size and
shape two little discs of sweet potato
which I will saute up
egg over medium on top of the sweet
potato almost like Benedict except
instead of English muffin it's the sweet
potato
that's not bad
um
trying to think that's basically my I
mean it's some something like that I
might make avocado toast if I'm more of
a bread mood or something like that but
those are those are my breakfasts I am
not into uh I haven't had cereal in who
knows how long I'm a fan of oatmeal but
not for breakfast I like yogurt but not
for breakfast all right let's move on
because this is just a waste of
everybody's time I hope I've answered
the question sufficiently on the bonus
show today European Parliament calls for
a flat out ban on facial recognition
some people say ban the virus and get
rid of it European Parliament is saying
ban facial recognition
in Texas a man has been sentenced to 15
months in prison for posting covid-19
hoaxes on social media very serious and
Los Angeles has indeed approved that
strict coveted vaccination mandate that
on Monday we said could be coming they
have approved it they have approved it
um I will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
how do you get access to the bonus show
it could not be simpler you go to
joinpakman.com
and you get a membership if you'd like a
discount you can use the coupon code
better21 and if you'd rather pledge via
patreon you can also do that by going to
patreon.com davidpackman show people
worried where was Pat yesterday on the
bonus show Pat will be back with us soon
just me on today's bonus show and
tomorrow Pat will be back with us very
very soon uh after the Columbus Day
Holiday
join today I'll see you on the bonus
show Pat and I will see you very very
soon